the United States is so obsessively
protective of its currency that it
guards its security right down to the
specific fibers that comprise each bill
US currency may be the most
counterfeited money in the world
mccrane paper here in Dalton became the
supplier of paper for US currency in
1879 has held that contract ever since
then we are now the sole supplier of
currency paper for the US government
crane paper is special because of the
materials that we choose high quality
natural fibers cotton and flax fibers
which had traditionally been used in
textile making are still used for US
currency as opposed to ordinary papers
made today with wood pulp there are a
lot of clever people that work hard to
try to create counterfeits security
features in the 100 dollar note include
a watermark feature with the portrait of
Benjamin Franklin which is put in the
paper making process and then the most
prominent security features now the 3d
ribbon here
Western world and we are accustomed to
credit and digital electronic
transactions but one of the features of
currency paper of course is anonymity I
think that's partly why it's valued by
many around the world as they can
conduct transactions using money without
having traceability to it so a lot of
the world that still relies on this
tangible product paper and money